okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts today
um I was doing
I was drinking some tea okay not coffee
I've I've been coffee free blessings
said I couldn't do it
but I'm in coffee free for four months
okay and I was just talking to blessing
just now right blessing yeah and we were
talking about we should record this and
this is what I was talking about
how there's two people in society okay
there's thinkers and there's doers
and the thinkers are always mad at the
doers okay the thinkers because this is
what they do they sit in their caves
they sit in there whatever and they just
think
and I'm not saying we don't need both in
society but the thinkers are just
thinking they're think think think think
think think I have all these ideas I
just think and I think and I think and
the doers are like
[__] that I'm gonna do I'm just gonna do
it I'm gonna get it done I'm gonna do it
and the doers are not afraid of doing
things badly and they're not afraid of
doing things badly they make a choice
they stick with that choice they don't
think about all the things that are
going to go wrong they don't think about
all this where the thinkers they will
always think about the risks in a
situation they're always mitigating
risks so they're like oh that could go
wrong or that could go wrong or that
could go wrong or the doers are just
like that's a good idea I want to do it
let's do it they don't care if they do
it badly they don't care if they get
they they [__] you know mess it up sorry
guys I said I'd stop swearing
are you laughing blessing what's funny
am I wrong
did I did I miss anything I said earlier
the kissing movie oh yeah
sorry guys sorry guys I'm a feminine
woman
sorry I'm improving I'm improving myself
instead of [__]
I'll say
there's just not a good filler I'll stop
I'll just I'll take it out of it my bad
my bad sorry sorry okay so the thinkers
they're thinking about all the stuff
that's gonna go wrong and the doers just
do it okay
and the the thinkers get resentful of
the doers because what the thinkers will
do is they'll say well I had that idea
first and I've been thinking about this
for years
I've been I've been thinking longer than
you've been alive I've been thinking
just think think thinking you know and
the doers will be like well well you've
been thinking I've been doing
and doers also they get in the most
trouble you know doers are the ones
that'll get a bad business partner screw
them over they'll you know they might
get stolen from the doers always bounce
back though because you know they they
just look at it as as part of what part
of life right you know [__] going wrong
they're like okay at some point
somebody's gonna screw me over at some
point some shit's gonna happen but I
don't care cause I'm a doer and I'm
gonna just do it and the thinkers they
think well that's a risk that's a risk
that's a risk that one happens so the
thinkers like they don't get in trouble
as much like they don't
things don't go wrong as much they have
more simple lives we're the doers
the crazy stuff happens to them which is
good but also bad because they'll have a
bad business partner you know an intern
that maybe steals money from them you
know a you you get it you get it it's
just different things okay go wrong
now let's let's go back to the thinkers
the thinkers get resentful of the doers
and they often feel like the doers don't
deserve their position
they don't deserve where they're at in
life because you know I've just had this
idea or these thoughts or these whatever
for so many years and that everyone
should like my product or my idea or my
whatever and they just get mad at the
doers and the doers are just like okay
you know that's fine you could do your
thing
but while you're busy whining we're busy
doing
what else did I miss about the thinkers
and the doers what else was I saying
earlier
I think Trump is the epitome Trump is
the epitome of a doer now guys I'm not a
die-hard trump fan
kind of like the guy I won't lie to you
guys you know he he's cool but but I'm
not gonna be a die-hard he's not the
hill I'm gonna die on but one thing as a
as a doer
one doer recognizes another doer Trump
is the type of guy to just do
and I'm not saying doers it doesn't mean
we get everything done right doers they
they sometimes get things done
and [__] gets in the way and yeah it's
kind of like if you try to do something
it doesn't work the doer will just move
on to the next thing right you know like
Trump's wall let's just be honest
these Democrats they're being Holes
about it
we cannot stand not making progress on a
project this will drive the doer insane
mad you will see the worst side of a
doer if you get in the way of their
project whatever their goal is you will
you will see them throw temper tantrums
you'll think that is the worst side of a
doer where the Thinker they'll just
they'll see they'll maybe see the the
roadblocks coming because they've been
thinking about this for years so they
knew that would happen
where the doers like how how the hell
did that happen so the doer often times
will have projects that are maybe subpar
okay if a thinker ever gets a project
done which it'll take them 20 years to
figure one project let me tell you the
the doer the Doer
we'll get that same project done in a
couple of months but the problem is it's
a lower quality right it's not as good
as it could have been if the doer just
thought about that that that and that
but the doer just doesn't think like
that
the thinkers think like that now doers
and thinkers should work together
they make the the perfect partnership
because the doer like the trumps and
honestly Pence and Trump kind of remind
me of a thinker and a doer I don't know
I'm gonna be honest so you could correct
me the political people I'm political
but I'm not that political
now
the like Pence Mike Pence have you seen
Mike Pence yeah he reminds you of a
thinker
right that's the type of guy that's
gonna think about all the problems
now the best thinkers are the ones that
don't need the credit okay because let's
be honest nothing but and I'm partial to
doers
they like they need each other thinkers
and doers but the problem is if the
Thinker
feels like like imagine if Pence wanted
the credit of trump how would that go
for him
how would that go for him
if if Pence wanted he wanted the credit
for everything that got done Mike Pence
how would that go for him
conflict yeah there because doers are
typically proud of doing [__] and when
they get something done they feel like
they're
they they're the ones that got it done
where the thinkers the thinkers they're
like well I have thought about this
and the doers are like so
I did it
so but they're the perfect Max when they
can actually like Mike and Pence to me
that seems perfect Pence doesn't really
seem to have the ego he doesn't really
seem to need the credit for doing stuff
or for thinking you know where Trump is
just like all right we're gonna do this
and if this doesn't work we're gonna do
that we're gonna get all this done
what else did I miss that I said earlier
anything else
I just want to make sure
I'll see you do as well yeah Kanye is a
doer and some of his albums people will
[__] on right yeah people will say that
was a bad album
but he did it
and if he's I don't know the history of
Kanye as much
but usually the doers will have 10 times
more
albums or whatever the thing is because
they're doer they'll just get it done
does he have more albums than who's a
thinker rapper when you think of a
thinker
I'll say in producing let's say Dr Dre
was a banker and we've been waiting on
an album for that 15 years Dr Dre is a
thinker where Kanye's the Doer
um
and you know oftentimes when The Thinker
puts something out a lot of times it's
beautiful
a lot of times not always
a lot of times it's better than what the
what the did the dinner the doer put out
but
other times the doer has just done it so
many times like you know maybe Kanye had
10 albums doctors I don't I don't know
rap guys so please don't roast me Dr Dre
had maybe two
and one out of TR out of the two
is better than most of the things that
Kanye's put out maybe
but and out of the ten maybe two of
Kanye's albums were phenomenal right but
Kanye still had two and Dre had one and
that's usually the epitome of the
thinkers and the doers
foreign
and the thinkers usually the thinkers
are whiners I'm not gonna lie because
they're mad they're mad because they
just don't have it in them to do
and they're the biggest crit I don't
again please don't please don't hold me
to the rap stuff I don't know but but I
don't know if this is what they do so
you could tell me if I'm right or I'm
wrong but the thinkers are always so
critical of the doers because they they
feel like they they had to wait their
turn to get there they feel like they
you know they went through all these
steps of thinking they went through all
these processes and they they can't even
imagine this young doer getting further
than them because they've been thinking
they've been thinking and so they're
like well I put all this thinking time
into this you just throw anything out
and the doers are like hell yeah I'll
throw anything out I'll I'll make a
mistake I'll make another mistake I'll
[__] that one up I'll [__] that album up
but at the end I will have something
beautiful and the the doers or the
thinkers are like well
you shouldn't put out all that like if
you're gonna do it you better be perfect
or good or like to the Quality they want
but they're just thinkers that's how the
thinkers are thinkers are whiners
usually the best thinkers are the
thinkers that want to be with the Doer
they see the value in the doer and they
want to work with the Doer
but a lot of thinkers they get this big
ego
because they're the king they're the
king or the queen of the thinking
and that's the thinkers and the doers my
friends
anyone else any anyone else
is that true with Dr Dre is he critical
of the young people or no
I don't know who he is I don't know I
don't know about that but I know to a
degree that it's just he just thinks
that law he hasn't done in
him he's a thing
okay well guys let me know I could be
right it could be wrong let me know if
there's another category you should put
the thinkers the doers
oh you're right there's a third category
they don't think or do they're just
idiots but we don't talk about them
because they're not really relevant they
just
they just they work for the thinkers or
their doers the thinkers are the doers
employ them but mostly the doers but I'm
impartial okay anyways guys let me know
what you think like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel also
guys sign up for our email list um we
are going to do
um events where I'm gonna give a coffee
talk on the stage
basically we do whiteboard videos and
we're gonna do it on a stage so anyone
if you have a thought you have
something like something you can give a
five minute whiteboard presentation on
sign up for my email list because that's
something I want to do anyways like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I will talk to you next time